let's start our class with a tiny bit of
review we're in this terribly exciting
part of Cs 109 where we are transer
transferring from Pure probability
Theory into the basics and core
principles of machine learning and
particularly what the rest of Cs 109 is
going to look like is we're going to
build up the foundations of classic
machine learning algorithms and then
talk about how those are the basis of
the thing called Deep learning which we
might have learned about but really all
the Theory comes from these three
different mechanisms for estimating
parameters in fact this one single task
perhaps is the heart and soul of what
you call machine learning and what is
modern artificial intelligence and it's
such a straightforward task it's amazing
to think about the impact it's had and
the straightforward task is you have
some parameters and you need to figure
out what they
are to put that that in other words in
CS 109 we've often had either random
variables or probabilistic models that's
just you know more random variables
being random together and when we had
those random variables a lot of times
those random variables would be defined
by numbers and those numbers we're going
to now be calling
parameters before this section of Cs 109
we would always give you those numbers
we would tell you you have a normal and
here's the mean and here's its
variance but now we're going to start
talking about calling those things
parameters and talking about the problem
of estimating those parameters Based on
data and parameters could be from single
random variables but just to be clear it
gets really exciting when you get into
problemistic models and problemistic
models still have parameters those are
these magical numbers that showed up in
our model and parameter estimation the
task of choosing those numbers based off
of data uh is the same problem whether
it's one random variable or
multiple and the reason we care so much
the reason it is such a big deal is
because most of artificial intelligence
looks like a three-step process the
first step is find a real world problem
that you think is worth solving and then
model the problem and when you model the
problem you might end up with a bean
Network or you may end up with a single
random variable but we always think
about this model as having parameters
and we're going to call those parameters
Theta so the first step of solving a
real world problem is to model it and
then the second step is almost always
okay you've got a model and it's got
some Theta based on some historical data
can I choose what those values of the
parameters are we call this training um
and you know you could have different
algorithms for estimating those
parameters uh and the result will be a
model with numbers you'll have a model
with numbers for each of those important
parameters so if I could rephrase
machine learnings it's basically
parameter estimation uh for
probabilistic models
there's several algorithms we can use
one of the most popular ones is the one
that we learned on
Monday the one that we learned on Monday
started with a really nice simple
intuition if I give you data for example
I give you all this data points I tell
you that my model for where these data
points come from is a gaussian and your
job is to choose
parameters the idea is for different
settings of parameters those data points
will look more or less likely and the
simple idea of the algorithm we talked
about on Monday is what if we just chose
the parameters that make the data look
as likely as possible this has a name
it's called maximum likelihood
estimation and the sorts of problems
that you'll have to solve will often
look like this I'll be like here's a
data set I assume that each of these
numbers is coming from you know a
particular model that model has a
parameter in in this case is Alpha and
could you estimate Alpha the the answer
for mle will be a little equation that
you could use you can say take each of
these data points which we call exis sum
up the log of them n divided by that
number that's going to be my estimate
for the parameter but how do we get
there well we use the mle intuition and
then Emily intuition starts with let's
write down How likely is are all my data
points based on a given state of the
parameter so if the parameter was a
different Alpha you would get a
different value for How likely all the
data points look and because we assume
the data points are IID this likelihood
is a big old
product now we would like to just choose
the alpha that makes this as large as
possible but we have this cool intuition
that the alpha that makes this large is
same as the alpha that makes the log of
this expression large and it turns out
the log of this expression which could
be written like this or Rewritten like
this is much easier to work with
choosing the alpha that maximizes this
log of the expression is way easier than
original thing and so almost always
we're going to be choosing an alpha that
maximizes the log likelihood because
logs are monotonic whichever Alpha makes
this the largest will be the same Alpha
that makes this the largest yay thank
you
logs so now all you have to do is choose
whichever Alpha makes this equation as
big as
possible there's a few different ways of
doing it but all the different methods
that I know about for choosing an alpha
to make this equation as large as
possible are going to require you to
take the derivative of this equation
with respect to Alpha this derivative
will be the key to choosing the biggest
Alpha possible can I pause here for a
second because maybe people had
questions that was a lot of content that
we covered on
Monday questions thoughts concerns yes
what's the difference between likelihood
and probability ah likelihood and
probability are sound very
synonymous but likelihoods a particular
term which is the probability of the
data I
saw so in this case you know this is the
probability of my whole data set and so
likelihood is a probability if you use
likelihood synonymously with probability
in all CS 109 no one would blink an eye
but if you want to be really really
really pedantic which I don't want to be
technically it is the probability of a
data
set does that answer the question and to
find like the likelihood of a single
event we use the um the PF yeah so the
likelihood of the entire data set is
going to be the product cuz they're
they're independent of the likelihood of
each data point each data point x sub I
that's my notation for one data point
it's likelihood is just the probability
density function if it was discret you'd
use the probability Mass function if it
was a model you would put the joint
probability here good questions very
good questions okay we're getting our
mle review
done rocking and rolling so what's the
story so far we have this beautiful
Philosophy for choosing parameters now
it uses this cool bit of math and the
hardest thing will be choosing an alpha
to make this as large as possible we
know that we'll need a derivative but so
far in this review I haven't really
talked about how to use the
derivative I want to start by just
mentioning this hidden mysterious
problem we have to solve which is if you
want to choose an alpha that makes this
as large as possible that's not the
easiest thing to
do one thing we know how to do is we can
take the derivative and in Monday's
class we use a particular hack to find
the
argmax and that particular hack was we
know that the maximum will be at a place
where the derivative is equal to zero
and for some equations it turns out if
you just put in zero you can solve for
Alpha and then you get the right answer
it's not a very general method not many
times in my life as a mathematician do I
use this method because it doesn't
really apply nicely when you have models
uh it doesn't always it's not always
guaranteed to work because you know the
derivative of zero could also be a
minimum there could be several Maxima
there's lots of reasons that what we
used on Monday is a bit of a hack so
Story So Far machine learning is all
based on parameter estimation one of the
great theories for parameter estimation
is maximum likelihood estimation we can
get this log likelihood function and we
want to choose the parameters that make
that as large as possible that's going
to require us to do some optimization we
have a pretty crummy method for
optimization right
now so that's the end of review and
where i' really like to continue this
conversation is can I just give you a
better method for optimization now
certainly you can take entire class at
Stanford where you learn about
optimization all these different ways
for choosing AR solving ARG
Maxes but if there's one algorithm that
every single person in Stanford CS
should know it is this method for
optimization it's not Lon King not
everyone has to watch Lon King though
you know fine movie what you need to
know is this other method for
optimization AKA another method for
doing argmax and that's called gradient
descent or gradient
asent it goes like
this let's say you're trying to choose
the Theta which is the argmax of some
function and let's say particularly this
is the function you're trying to find
the argmax of just as a bit of riew
before I jump into the
algorithm is this the
argmax he yell it come on is this the
argmax is this it is this it is this it
is this
it is that it
yeah hey how easy would argmax be if
somebody just gave you a visualization
of the entire likelihood function like
if somebody visualized as you change
Theta all the different values of lik
Hood choosing argmax would be so simple
you just kind of look at the curve and
you'd be done but that's really really
really computationally expensive you
have to try you have to calculate
likelihood for every possible input of
theta too much work people don't do that
if you have more than one Theta becomes
exponentially
bad so if you can't see this blue curve
is there another way of getting the
Theta that takes you to the top of the
mountain and I still give you the fact
that you know the derivative for any
Alpha you can calculate the likelihood
and you can calculate the derivative of
the
likelihood it' be too much effort to
calculate the likelihood for every Alpha
that will take too much work but can we
use a more clever algorithm to get to
the top of the mountain and a lot of you
guys might have seen this before so let
me just remind those who have seen it
and teach those who have not seen it
before the very simple idea is Imagine
you start with any Theta you choose an
initial value maybe you choose zero
maybe you choose 50 doesn't really
matter which one you choose because that
will not be your final guess for the
argmax you can only see what's in Red so
you choose a Theta you look at the
likelihood of your Theta and you can
know the derivative at that point you
can't see the whole blue curve but let's
say if you look at the derivative you
know that the derivative is like this
that means if you increase Theta you
think likelihood will go up CU it's a
positive derivative so if the derivative
is positive do you think we should takea
to the right or to the
left is that from your perspective
larger value of theta if we increase the
value of theta because the slope is
positive the slope's telling us that
uphill is this way increased Theta
should lead to increased likelihood so
even though we can't see the Blue Line
we know that going this way should make
likelihood go up so the very simple
algorithm is start anywhere figure out
which direction is uphill and take a
step in that direction so maybe we take
one step in this direction now we can
see what's in the red we're here we can
know that we've improved and we can also
know the derivative the derivative is
not as steep but it's still positive
it's still telling us that uphill is
that direction so imagine you're a
climber and you're somewhere on a
mountain you can't see the whole
Mountain what a weird Mountain to be
climbing maybe it's very foggy but you
do know that uphill is this direction
and if you want to get to the top of
that Hill you go in that direction so
very simply if uphills in this direction
let's go that way boom boom boom boom
boom and if we repeat this process
enough eventually we'll get to the top
and at this point you are still the Red
Dot but you're that final Red Dot you
can't tell that you're at the top of the
mountain but what you can do is you can
look at your
gradient and you can figure out that my
gradient is zero so my slope is zero
that means no direction is going to take
me up any anymore and therefore I think
I've made it to the top of a mountain
how simple is that algorithm some people
call it hill climbing some people call
this gradient Ascent now of course we
don't care about the likelihood we cared
about the Theta that gave that
likelihood and so we would just run this
algorithm and return back Theta this is
the number one most important algorithm
that you need to know in optimization
there's people who do slightly fancier
versions of this adaptive gradients is a
thing you know people have improved upon
this but this is the core Insight that
people use when they're doing something
like training in neural network they're
going to try and choose parameters that
argmax something and they use hill
climbing questions ideas yeah um what's
the size of the step you set constant
how annoying is that like what happens
if you over shoot oh my God that would
be a
disaster okay the question is what's the
size of the step and I'm telling you
that you have to choose that number
before you run the algorithm so let's
run the algorithm I've got an imagined
curve and let's say you choose a really
big step size so you start here gradient
this way so you take a huge step and you
step over
here and now you take the gradient here
and it's
negative and you take a huge step and
you end up over here and you end up with
a positive gradient ideally you'll start
narrowing in on the top there is a
possibility though if you keep taping
huge steps it's like you keep leaping
over the top of the mountain and you
never converge to the top so small step
sides guarantee you converge but it'll
take more longer to get there is it
eventually disc into a sort of binary
search then you can think of it as
having some binary search capacities yes
but step size does matter so your
original question was really good you
know if your step size is too big you're
going to have to choose a number which
I'll talk about in second and that's an
important choice yes is this sort of
similar to what we did in the last
lecture where you were just like putting
in numbers and like seeing if it was
going up and going down I mean yeah a
little bit so the question is is this
similar to what I did at the beginning
of last lecture so just to remind people
at the beginning of last lecture I did
this thing right where I was trying in
different parameters and I was seeing
what was the largest it's a little bit
smarter when I was doing this I wasn't
looking at gradients I was just looking
at likelihoods and this time I'm also
going to be looking at gradients and
that's going to guide the computer and
actually that's what's going to allow
the computer to really do this both
automatically and a lot more efficiently
so does that make sense what a cool
question yes another question um do we
assume that the graph that we look at
always looks like that in SS of having
like one single pump like hump that
could have have like two humps or like
two P at some point with okay so
imagine the mysterious
foggy log likelihood function remember
we're trying to choose log likelihood of
our Theta you want the Theta that
maximizes it which one of these is the
argmax this
one no this one yeah but what if you did
hill climbing and you started here you
go uphill uphill uphill uphill uphill
and then you get here and be like I'm at
the top of the mountain woohoo and you
would return not the best parameters
ever which is a little bit sad not
really the end of the world but a little
bit sad okay if you were feeling super
hacky how would you solve this
oh you have an idea you taking like 20
AI
classes what's your idea do it again
yeah do it again there's a this is the
really hacky thing that people actually
do is they'll choose random starting
positions and be like oh I started here
and I got to the top here I started here
and I ended up at this spot again but
then like one time I start here and I
end up over here and another time I
start here I end up over here and you
know I ran it four times and out of
those I this was the top of the mountain
that I found super hacky but people
actually do it people are
crazy and then they they present
themselves like very elegant machine
learning
theorists now I do want to note that not
every problemistic model only has one
parameter a gaussian for example has two
parameters if you had a whole beijan
network you could have hundreds of
parameters this method works even if you
have more than one parameter so if you
have more than one parameter your log
likelihood function becomes you know a
three-dimensional graph where you know
High values on this third dimension
means High log likelihoods and we'd
still like to get to the top the
parameters that have the highest log
likely and it'll be a combination of
parameters that lead to high log
likelihoods and you know you could have
different starting points and you can
still use hill climbing and hill
climbing you just need a derivative with
respect to each parameter and if you
have a derivative with respect to each
parameter you you can know which way is
uphill and it works with more than two
parameters does it work with more than
two oh yeah it works with three four and
five but our puny little human visual
system can only visualize two parameters
optimizing at the same time but the same
algorithm works if you have hundreds of
parameters and you're trying to jointly
optimize all of
them what's confusing about this
questions okay so this whole algorithm
works the only thing you need to do to
be able to use this is you need to know
the derivative of thing you want to
optimize with respect to each parameter
that's the thing that you must do that's
your work and if you do that work then
you can just use uh optimization I have
really good news almost every single
optimization that you do in CS 109 will
be functions that have a very beautiful
property which is called that they're
convex and convex has this nice property
that if you find an Optima it will be
the global Optima so we don't have to do
any of these like really complicated
hacks uh if you're curious to go deeper
about convex let's talk about that
offline now if I had to give you that
algorithm written in mathematical
notation here's what it would look like
when you're choosing a new you will
continually update your guess for the
best parameter when you're choosing your
next guess you're going to take your old
guess and then you're going to figure
out the derivative of likelihood at your
current Point multiply that derivative
by some constant and then add that to
your guess so if your derivative is
positive constant is always positive if
your derivative is positive then Theta
will increase in value if your
derivative negative then your Theta will
decrease in value and we will repeat
this many many times and isn't this such
profound life philosophy we do not need
to just jump to the top of a mountain if
every day you wake up and figure out
which way is uphill and take a small
step uphill you will eventually make it
to the top top of your
mountain is that such a nice way to live
okay other nice things gradient
Ascent now if I to give you that exact
same thing in code you could have many
parameters give them all initial random
starting points and then many times
calculate the gradient and then run that
update equation where each parameter you
add to it a constant step size times the
gradient for that parameter the gradient
of log likelihood for that parameter
that means that you will have to do some
work every step you'll have to calculate
a gradient um and you know if we go back
to that example from last class of
fitting the Paro this was the gradient
we calculated we had a log likelihood
function it was based on a parameter
Alpha and we figured out the derivative
of the log likelihood with respect to
Alpha was this thing if you want to
actually Implement that you would have
to turn this math equation into
code and if you could turn this math
equation into into code then this would
give you the best choice of alpha start
Alpha at some random start then many
times calculate the gradient of alpha
based on the data and then change Alpha
based off of the gradient you just
calculated now of course you can't just
type latch into a computer but it
wouldn't be too hard to turn this into
Python and just to show you what that
would look like it would look like this
many times when you're calculating the
gradient you know start it out as this
value and then you're going to have to
calculate this term so start it out as n
/ Alpha and then for every XI in your
data you get its log and you subtract it
off of that when you're done with this
whole expression you'll have the
gradient for
Alpha based on the current Alpha you had
and your data
points and then you update questions
comments concerns wow optimization
changes the world yes will we ever be
expected to find the global maximum or
if there's more than one will the local
be enough yeah CS 109 if you find the
local Maxima it will be the global
Maxima but I do want to be complete in
my Exposition because someday in the
world you may end up in a local Maxima
but you know what is perfection always
the goal we want maybe not other life
philosophy we can talk about that
offline okay but I do want to leave this
up for a second because this is what it
looks like to put into code and a lot of
times you know when we Implement our
machine learning algorithms later in CS
109 you'll write code that looks a lot
like this I want to do Max on my
parameters so I'll use gradient
Ascent okay has anyone oh yeah question
um for gradient Alpha why can we just
divide n by
Alpha um because that was my this was
this term so n will be a positive number
hopefully Alpha didn't start out at zero
um and an interesting thing Alpha will
change every time through this equation
and when I use Alpha it will be just my
current estimate of alpha okay but
basically this expression is the
derivative yeah this expression is
calculating the derivative and then
storing it into a
variable crazy a derivative can be
started as a variable yeah it will be
just a number at the end of the day the
derivative will be a value that whole
crazy expression becomes Whatever Gets
stored in that
bucket wow exciting has anyone ever
heard of an algorithm called gradient
descent it turns out every python
package every computational package you
ever use doesn't give you gradient
Ascent but I just told you it's the most
important thing ever it's because
everybody uses gradient descent every
package gives you an algorithm not to
find the highest point but to find the
lowest point it's because you want to
minimize regret or minimize loss if we
want to use a gradient descent algorithm
so a gr and decent algorithm you start
somewhere and it will give you the
lowest
point I want to maximize likelihood I
don't want to minimize
anything hackers
unite if you found a gradient descent
algorithm how could you use gradient
descent to choose a parameter that
maximizes a log
likelihood oh it's on the slides for
those who are fantastic at reading
yes yes exactly you know just this is an
aside in CS 109 you can always Implement
gradient scent but if you ever find a
package that does gradient descent
you'll notice that they will be
minimizing not the log likelihood but
the negative log
likelihood so normally we want to
maximize the positive log likelihood and
if somebody gives me gradient descent an
algorithm for gradient descent it'll
just minimize the negative log
likelihood again that's not so important
because in cs19 you'll always be writing
your algorithms from scratch but if you
ever find a log a library that that just
does it for you uh you just need to know
that descent will be a negative
fantastic okay I want to take a moment
this is early for pedagogical pause but
this is critical we just talked about
some of the most important things and if
you can solidify this knowledge then the
rest of lecture will be a lot easier to
follow so I want you guys to take a
minute I want you to think about what
we've learned I want you to see if you
can think about some question that you
care about feel free to talk about this
with the person next to you before we
jump into another way of doing parameter
estimation so what do we talk about and
what's confusing go for it take a minute
and a
half
e
it's got to be on the
top
but I think they
close let's talk about
after
okay let's bring it back together I
started writing the plot here just cuz I
want to make sure no one loses the plot
why are we doing this all of machine
learning is based off of parameter
estimation so far we have one great idea
for parameter estimation which is that
we can have a function uh a log
likelihood function which for any state
of the parameters we can say How likely
the data looks and then we want to
choose the parameters that make this log
likelihood as large as possible and so
we can choose that parameter that that
maximizes log likelihood using gradient
sent that's the plot so far but
questions probably came up there's
probably subp parts of this plot that
are confusing and if it's confusing to
you it's confusing to a lot of people I
love the questions in this class yes
what's the benefit of using a gradient
asent over the first method we discussed
just like
doing so it's a good question the why
would you use gradient Ascent instead of
the the first method the first method
was you take your derivative set equals
z and then just solve it's just that the
first method doesn't Sol work for
General problems for example this method
we just talked about this whole plot
line is going to work for deep learning
and deep learning you'll have a huge
neural network with millions of
parameters you want to choose the
parameters that maximize log likelihood
and when you have millions of parameters
you can't sit down and set all the
derivers equal to zero and solve for
them and so you're going to need a more
General algorithm so gradient descent is
the most General bread and butter
algorithm the setting equal to zero
Works in some cases but just not in all
what a cool question and I bet a lot of
people were wondering about
that I was used a lot last lecture was
the idea of an unbiased estimator we
have used that at all this lecture but I
wonder if you can talk a little bit more
about like what that means exactly
and so you know before we did
mle a different way for doing parameter
estimation was using the things that
taught us about a couple weeks ago where
you could estimate the sample mean and
there is an equation for that right you
can estimate the sample mean by taking
all your data points summing them up and
then dividing by n and you could
estimate the sample variance and you
could do you know that uh cool equation
that we had before where you take all of
your data points subtract off uh your
your guess of the sample
mean uh squared / 1 - nus
one these can be used for parameter
estimation not in general like the PTO
you couldn't use this for the prto but
you could use do this for very very
specific cases like if you're estimating
the mean and variance of a gaussian you
could use this if you were estimating
the P of a bruli you could use this
because it turns out this works out well
so for a very small class of problems
you could estimate parameters just by
figuring out these statistics and then
knowing how to calculate your parameters
based off the statistics does that make
sense it's not General though it doesn't
work for Paro distributions it doesn't
work for beijan networks it doesn't work
for deep learning so while that was a
nice idea we needed something general so
mle is general and gradient Ascent
they're General they work for any model
any parameters you might care
about okay
fantastic now this could be the end of
our plot line we could just be like
great we're done with machine learning
or we know the core theoretical basis of
it and this is one of the core iCal
bases but I want you to know why it
doesn't always work and particularly in
Monday's class we talked about one
reason it doesn't work and to put that
into words it's that mle likes to
overfit the data it's seen it's choosing
the parameters that makes the data it's
seen look as likely as possible it
doesn't think about data it might not
have seen so for example if you're
fitting a uniform and it got this data
it will choose parameters that make
makes that data look as likely as
possible without imagining that there
will be data
outside so mle if it had to fit a
uniform to this sets the minimum to be
the smallest value in this list and the
maximum parameter to be the largest
value but if you've only seen seven
points How likely is it that one of the
points we saw was exactly the Min and
How likely is it that one of the points
we saw is exactly the
max it's overfitting to the small amount
of data it's given those parameters that
comes up with are not very general in
fact these values I chose 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 I can tell you that MLD did a very bad
job of using those parameters because I
generated those seven numbers from a
uniform whose true Min was zero and
whose true max was one and you just
happen to see 0.15 as your smallest
value because if you only see seven data
points you're not going to get something
too close to the true Min you're not
going to see something too close to the
two Max so you'll hear a lot of people
talking machine learning about
overfitting it's when the parameters you
choose describe your data set too well
and they don't describe things that
you'll see in the future very well so ml
is great but it does have this little
problem now for a little bit of
foreshadowing I am going to need a
volunteer it's got to be somebody who
hasn't volunteered
before you come on up and we are going
to play a game as you make your way up I
will explain the game though please ask
questions if you have any I have two
envelopes one is labeled a and one's
label B before we play this game what's
your name nice to meet you I am Chris
hey everybody this is class classes did
I say that
right everybody this is a class A little
round of applause for our wonderful
volunteer okay I have two envelopes I'm
going to allow you to have one
I'll take a yeah good
choice here is the game and it's a wild
one also if the lights bothers you can
stand over
here one of these envelopes contains X
and the other envelope contains $2 X so
you got an envelope and you can look
inside okay so now here is the question
do you want to switch I've given you
information I told you one envelope has
X and one envelope has $2 X before you
make your decision do you want to see
some math sure do you want to know the
expected amount of money in the other
envelope and and everyone else in class
pay attention because we're going to
help make an optimal decision so maybe
you want to choose this based on the
expected amount of money in this
envelope so let's say that why is the
amount of money in the
envelope if you think about the expected
amount of money in the other envelope
there's a 50% chance that this has twice
as much money and a 50% chance it has
half as much money so there's you know a
50% chance you've got y over two and a
50% chance of 2 y you do lot of total
expectation and you get that the
expected amount of money in here is 5
over4 y isn't that
wild
now what do you think about switching it
now I want everyone to think we're going
to get to pull the audience we're going
to say do you want to do you guys think
you recommend I switch or I don't switch
so I want you guys to think expectation
says in expectation there's more money
in the other
envelope but you might have other
opinions expectations is not the end of
the world it's not the only thing we can
do in
probability okay do you want to give
them some time to think or should we
make them make their decision I'll give
them time to yeah yeah that sounds good
okay you guys think lot on the
line it's why
right I guess that means that it could
either be $80 or
$20 you can wait opinions however you
want
okay this envelope could have $80 or it
could have
$20 and since $80 is so much larger in
expectation switching always seems like
a good strategy but now wants to get
your advice who who says switch who says
doesn't switch first just make your
noise say switch or no switch no switch
oh wow do you want to see hands or was
that clear enough feel like said no
switch Yeah that seemed like but
expectation says you should switch but
you can choose no switch that's a fair
Choice I'll choose okay do you want to
know what's in the other one there's in
fact 20 you made the right okay
everybody good advice thank you very
much take a seat yeah yeah yeah but I
want the
envelope hard to find
envelopes now that is interesting
everybody says don't switch and yet
expectations said that there is more
likely to be money in the other
envelope and I'm going to say that
there's a bug in our thinking which is
similar to the bug in mle if you got to
play this game a whole bunch of times
you could figure out um a lot of
interesting things and particularly one
of the things that you could figure out
is when we made this calculation I
assumed it was equally likely that there
was $20 and just as likely that there
was $80 in the other
envelope if you could play this game
many many many many times you could
actually get better at estimating those
you could be like Chris never puts $80
he don't have that kind of
money uh and you could become more and
more intelligent about this and in fact
though even without playing this many
times times I can tell you that this is
really misleading this idea that it's
just as likely to have half as much
money as double as much money and to
drive that point home let's say you
opened the first envelope this is back
when I was younger and didn't have $40
to my name and it could have had $10 in
it if you claim that $20 and $5 are
equally
likely if you were curse on that
assumption you could say $40 must then
also be equally likely and $80 must be
equally likely and then $160 must be
equally likely it turns out there's
infinite powers of Two And if you have
infinite values that are equally likely
you no longer have a valid probability
distribution and you're claiming that
it's equally likely that I have $20 in
my envelope as it is that I have like
two you know like to the 50th Dollar in
my envelope and we know that that's just
not true I'm a
professor so that was a brok broen
assumption and the broken assumption you
know it could have been solved in a few
different ways one way you could have
solved it is you could have played this
game a whole bunch of times if you
played this game hundreds of times or if
you watched all the past videos of Cs
109 you could have realize that there's
a pretty tight distribution over the
amounts of money I'll put in envelopes
but the problem is I only let you play
this game once and there are so many
contexts in the world in your algorithms
in problems that you'll want to solve
where you don't get to have a ton of
data you don't get to play a game many
times before you have to make a decision
under
uncertainty and one of the ways to solve
this is before you walk into the game
you have a prior belief you use all your
knowledge of Chris and what sort of
things I might put in envelopes and you
encode that in a way that's not through
experimentation and bean prior beliefs
is a really good way to talk about that
you can have sub objective probabilities
you can have beliefs before you see any
data um now of course by extension if
you have a prior belief all posterior is
have some subjectivity in them um but
it's really helpful when you have to
answer questions when you have limit to
no data and it can also be very very
helpful when you would like to not
overfit the data that you've seen so
far so your subjective probability if
you had a belief about envelopes before
you might think 20 is a pretty likely
number for Chris to put it and like 10's
possible but I think that the
probabilities of these other numbers are
somehow smaller and particular like it's
very unlikely that I put $1 in because
if I put $1 in then you'd kind of be
able to weigh the other one be like
there's no coins in here uh and
similarly it's really unlikely I put $5
in because then you know $2.50 would
also be really easy to way you can have
a really strong prior belief about
what's in this envelope and my claim is
you guys all knew the right answer and
the reason you knew the right answer is
because in your brains you were holding
on to this subjective belief over How
likely different numbers were you in
yourselves felt that it was very
unlikely that I put $80 in there and
this is called this is a paradox and the
solution to the pars the reason humans
don't find this hard is because we have
strong
priors okay so oh we've already played
the game but in my first version I had
you standing up here through that whole
Exposition now if I could summarize the
major takeaways from
this probabilities really do have a
belief element to them and some level
probabilities representing what we don't
know about the world will help us make
better decisions so if you can
incorporate prior beliefs maybe when you
have small amounts of data you will make
better decisions you will overfit your
data less and you'll maybe end up with
better
parameters we've actually seen this play
out before
and I want to recall a problem from
earlier in class and I want to show you
the equivalent version as parameter
estimation earlier in class I gave you a
problem that says a medicine is tried on
20 patient it works for 14 and it
doesn't work for six what is your new
belief that the drug works that was a
question I asked you earlier but I could
have phrased this as a parameter
estimation question I said I could say
have 20 IID samples from beri estimate p
here's your data 16 1es and or sorry 14
1es and 6
zeros now if you set up this problem we
can now just throw in mle and mle if you
worked out the mle estimate we talked
about what it is for bruli is just the
average so you'd sum up all these values
and divide by 20 and that would give you
14 divid by 20 mle would just give you
07 but we saw this particular problem
earlier in class we actually had a
different way of solving it that didn't
require us to use this particular plot
line in this case we had a much more
elegant way of talking about the
probability uh parameter P we had this
elegant conversation about a thing
called a beta you said I can have a
prior belief in what my parameter is and
then I can update my belief in what p is
after I saw data and this was so elegant
for two reasons the first reason was El
an is like the envelope example it
allows for you to incorporate what you
know before you start doing any
experiments maybe you know something
about these drugs and you can
incorporate that information so it's
stronger for that reason it was also
stronger for the other reason which is
instead of just giving you about a
single number it gave you a whole
distribution around that number so you
can express not just that I think 71 is
the most likely value of P but I can
also talk about my confidence so for a
few reasons
what we did earlier was more elegant
than what we're doing now now reason we
haven't seen this in place of
mle is because that worked for the P of
a
beri could we take that same beautiful
idea and make it work for other
parameters CU if we could then maybe we
could do a little bit better than mle
and we could learn about our final
estimator so today the plot line is
going to diverge and and we're going to
be learning about a different way that
we could do our estimations and it's
going to be a beian policy that we're
going to talk about called maximum a
posteriori and really what it's going to
allow us to do is going to allow us to
incorporate prior for parameter
estimation it will be a different method
for choosing our
parameters I would like to introduce it
by contrasting it explicitly with
mle mle says hey you want parameters pal
I'll give you parameters how I'm going
to give you parameters is I will choose
the parameters that maximize the
likelihood of your data which parameters
make the data look as likely as
possible the beian approach looks very
similar but if you're very attentive
you'll notice it answers a slightly
different question there is another way
of estimating parameters it says yo pal
you want parameters I'll get you
parameters but I'm not mle I'm going to
give you more elegant
parameters instead of
choosing the parameters that make the
data most likely I'm going to choose the
parameters that are the most
likely given the values of the
data I saw I saw like 20 heads go like
what yeah you know the these are
slightly different philosophies right
this is
saying what makes the data looks likely
and this is saying what's the most
likely
parameter they're slightly different
they're the conditional in the
reverse and when you put the conditional
in the reverse then we're going to have
to solve this using a different
mechanism and that different mechanism
is going to invoke base
theorem and you know this is the
unknowable as the parameter and the data
is the observable so this is the more
natural direction to express in terms of
equations we have likelihood functions
whereas this is something that we don't
exactly know how we would have to solve
for
it just to be clear these two different
philosophies are going to lead to two
different algorithms because we never
did this algorithm directly instead we
did the log likelihood we would argmax
over the log likelihood and similarly
we're going to do some manipulations to
make this easier to work with but today
we're going to learn about our final
estimator and the final estimator starts
by taking a different philosophical
stance and the idea of the different
philosophical stance is it will allow us
to incorpor at priors it allow us to
come up with maybe better estimates
especially when we have small amounts of
data okay so a little bit of shorthand
because I'm going to have to write
equations like this over and over again
and I want to be clear that when I use
shorthand I don't lose people so we're
thinking about our parameters now as
being random variables just like the
beta and we want to choose the
assignment to those random variables
that are the most likely given the
assign ments to the IID samples we have
but I'm going to start using Theta as
Shand for the event of the random
variables for theta equals Theta and XI
as Shand for the event the I data point
takes on the value uh that we saw in the
database also one small thing did you
notice how I used to have the I data
point using a subscript and now I've
moved to a
superscript I'm just trying to gently
get us ready for when we get to machine
learning algorithms on Friday and Beyond
because when we get to machine learning
algorithms our data points will have
multiple values per data point so I'm
just going to start putting my eyes as
superscripts but this is still saying
XI using this shorthand notation I'm
still saying choose the thetas that are
the most likely given the data points
that we've
observed okay let's jump
in but give people a moment let that
sink in it's like okay it's mle but
flipping the conditional that seems fine
will it actually be different H we'll
find
out okay
um
now just to be clear if you estimating
the most likely value of a parameter
given data for a particular model of a
bruli so I'm telling you all your data
points come from a
beri if you wanted to choose you know
the values of the most likely value of
theta given my beri data so that could
be like heads equals 16 and Tails or
heads equals 14 and taals equals
6 we already know how to think about
this probability this would actually be
a beta distribution so if you said you
know what is the distribution of the
likelihoods of the parameters given the
data you have observed we know this will
come out to a beta
distribution in the case of a bruli and
then if we put an ARG Max
here it's saying which value of theta
has the highest value and this is
actually technically a probability
density in the probability density of
theta when we did the beta distribution
these were you know X's because X was
our random variable for p but now I'm
using thetas because Thea is my more
General random variable for p so you
know if you say the distribution of your
your parameter given data you saw it is
a b or sorry it is a beta and if you say
ARG Max it will just
return the mode uh which is whichever
input to the beta has the highest
probability okay so before we get into
any heavy math I just want to tell you
that if you use this new philosophy this
map philosophy and if you used it to
estimate the parameter for a bruli or a
binomial it would be really really
straightforward because we've already
done the math for a beta because we've
already done the math for beta what this
would look like is you're going to have
to choose a prior belief in your
parameter you'll express that as a beta
recall that a beta with AB means that
you saw a minus one imaginary successes
and B minus one imaginary
failures before you started looking at
any data then you run an experiment
which is you start to see some data
points you'll see particularly n data
points of successes and M data points of
failures the
posterior of your belief in the
probability is going to be a new beta
and we derived this earlier where the
parameters of new beta is a which came
from our prior plus n that came from the
data we observed so imaginary successes
minus one plus true successes observed
and the second parameter is imaginary
failures minus one plus the true number
of failures that we observed so for
estimating just the P of um
beri you could end up with this
posterior belief over the parameter in
this case the p and your posterior
belief would be a beta once
again maximum a posterior then throws an
argmax around this so we saw this in
class maximum a posterior this other way
of choosing parameters will choose a
single number instead of giving you back
a full beta it will choose the number
which is whichever value makes the beta
as large as possible that is the mode
and it's always equal to um the first
parameter minus one divid by the sum of
the two parameters minus
2 it's always that for a beta
distribution so back to our plot line
and I'm not going to write this in green
because that's hard to
see we now have this core need you need
parameter estimation for machine
learning mle is great but it generally
overfits and it doesn't allow you to
have priors so we're going to have map
to eliminate P or to to not
overfit and while this is a good idea
and we can see how this would be a great
idea if we're estim P we have one huge
issue mle works for more than just SMP
parameter estimation is supposed to be
something general for any machine
learning model we should be able to
estimate parameters and while map
maximum a posterior that really fancy
term for just saying what's the most
likely parameters given my
data while that seems like a good idea
so far we've only seen it for estimating
a single parameter for a single type of
model it doesn't feel that
General I do have good
news people are like this seems like a
good idea let's get to work crew and a
whole bunch I imagine everybody had a
meeting and then everybody went and
figured out what's the way to do maximum
a posterior for a whole bunch of classic
random variables and they did and they
thrived and they had a good time
somebody figured out how did you do the
maximum a posterior for a p well we're
going to use a beta prior that's going
to lead to a beta posterior and then we
can just do the mode of the beta
fantastic that also works for binomial
then somebody's job was to do pan hey
you want to estimate the lambdaa great
you have to give me a prior there's a
particular distribution called a gamma
and if you express your prior as a gamma
then your posterior will also be a gamma
and then we can choose the uh the value
that maximizes your belief in Lambda by
choosing whatever maximizes the
posterior gamma same thing with the
exponential Lama um and people did
something for like the normal mean oh it
turns out your prior should also be a
normal and people did the same thing for
a normal of uh the variance of the
variance parameter in a normal uh and
each these somebody worked out the math
for how you could do maximum a
posterior I'm just going to show you a
few of these I'm going to show you what
it looks like for this Lambda uh in a
Pon I'm going to show you what it looks
like for multinomial and then I'm going
to show you the math that you could use
if you want to drive one yourself yes
explain again what a conjugate
distribtion yeah do you remember when we
talked about betas if you express your
prior as a beta and then you did Bay
theorem the posterior magically was
still in the form of a beta we call that
a conjugate when the form of a prior
matches the form of a posterior it's
really really nice in good times and so
when expressing prior beliefs we often
try and look for Expressions that have
this
property you need to come up with
conjugate prior yourself in cs1 no9 no
but is it nice to know that
um these are really good choices for
representing priors for these variables
you should know
that yes so does that mean re
representing the distribution parameter
completely as for example a beta instead
of bomal yeah so the binomial has a
parameter p and we now need a a random
variable type for p so even though P is
for binomial the variable for p itself
is a
beta you know Lambda is the parameter
for pant that's a good time but if you
were to turn Rand Lambda itself into a
random variable so you could choose the
most likely value of that random
variable the right format for that
random variable's distribution is a
gamma okay which we'll talk about in a
second so I understand the difference
between M and and like how you're
looking for um so for example in this
case you're trying to maximize the
likelihood
of
um intuitively it makes sense that the
most
liket give you values that are the most
likely obviously that's not true but
what's an example where this isn't the
case yeah so I
mean if the question is what's the
relationship between this and if you
flipped the conditional like in what
case is it different asking what is the
most likely value of parameters versus
what parameters make the data as likely
as possible I mean I'm jumping the plot
line a little bit but let's replace this
with
data so we want to
choose the parameters that are most
likely given the data and using base
theorem this will
be data given parameters times your
prior belief in the
parameters divided by some normalization
constants so I'll say that this is equal
to some you know divid by some constant
K notice this relationship if you think
this constant K doesn't change an argmax
which it
doesn't uh multiplying everything by a
constant won't change which argument
maximizes this
function if the argmax of this is equal
to the argmax of this your question is
what's the relationship between this
expression and this expression and when
when are they different and notice
there's a mathematical
relationship what's the difference
between the likelihood of your parameter
given your data and the likelihood of
your data given your parameter
to make them equal you have to multiply
this one by this term that is the term
that shows you how these two things are
different and what is that
term that's a little bit of a hard
question but I'm going to ask you you
ask me a hard question right so
it's going to be the value of of your
beta right like of that I mean more
generally what does it mean to talk
about the likelihood of the parameters
without any
data that's your prior that's your prior
let's write that in all
caps these two philosophies are
incredibly similar because these two
expressions are incredibly similar
there's just one term that makes them
different these things would be equal if
you took what we had from mle and
multiplied it by How likely you thought
those parameters were before you saw any
data aka the prior and if you could
incorp this term then you have a way of
choosing the parameters that are most
likely given the data what a wild ride
we're like throwing all the 109 things
you've got like conditional
probabilities you have parameters as
random variables and you have
optimization uh for parameter estimation
oh my God this is like throwing
everything at you guys all at once and
you got some Bas theorem just for good
measure to clarify the bottom equation
is as if we did the likelihood thing but
also Incorporated that specific graph of
how how you how we thought you're you're
going to put money in an envelope and
then it's the same as doing it the other
way yeah basically it will be the exact
same formula but we now will have a term
for How likely you thought parameters
were before you saw any
data and so we'll have a new language
for talking about that prior belief and
it'll hopefully make our estimation
better now I actually I don't want to go
over this too much because it's a little
bit rote in that there's not a lot of
deep Insight in these next few lines I
just want to tell you that people have
solved this for different parameters
like if you solve this equation for if
you want to come up with good ways of
expressing prior so that you could come
up with good posteriors I just want to
show you what it look like for a couple
of them if you want to choose a
Lambda one of the ways is you set a
prior belief and the prior belief that
you choose um for your Lambda it's like
I'm going to
imagine that I've seen some number of
imaginary time periods and in that
imaginary number of time periods I saw
some number of imaginary events and it's
your way of representing your belief in
the rate before you see any
data if you had that belief you can
express it in this new random variable
which you've not seen before but turns
out to be a useful way of expressing the
prior of a Lambda which is called a
gamma and it has exactly those two
parameters that we just mentioned you
know you could express your prior belief
as a gamma below before and then in your
experiment when when you're trying to
update your belief about the Lambda of
AA if you actually see n events in K
time periods if you express your prior
is a gamma your posterior will also be a
gamma and it will be you know your
imaginary number of events plus how many
events you actually saw and your
imaginary number of time periods plus
how many time periods you actually saw
just to give you a sense that people
have solved this this is how you would
end up with this is what map looks like
for
Lambda uh I want to skip this for a
second because I do want to jump to
actually solving this for
ourselves so so far you know you should
use a beta if you want to estimate P for
a berul I just told you you should use a
gamma if you want to estimate a Lambda
and I just want to really quickly tell
you that somebody has also solved this
for a multinomial remember multinomial
you're rolling a whole bunch of dice and
you want to know successes of each type
of outcome you can set up a prior that's
like the extension of a beta for a
multinomial and it has a really fancy
name called a dear slate but it's just a
beta for a multinomial in that prior
belief you say before I look at actual
dice rolles for my multinomial I'm going
to imagine that I saw A1 minus one
outcomes of type one A2 minus1 outcomes
of type two and a minus one outcomes of
Type M it's like a beta would just have
two different terms here number of zeros
a number of ones but a multinomial
extends that to M different outcomes and
the deay extends the beta to M different
outcomes as well it's the exact same
thing as a beta but with a few more
outcomes then if you actually observe N1
outcomes of type one and two alchs of
type two so like here was your prior you
actually collect some data if you chose
your prior Express as a deer slay your
posterior will also be a deer slay and
particularly won't just be any deer slay
we can know what deer slay it will be
and it's a imagine successes of type one
plus actual success of type one imagine
success of type two plus actual
successive type two and then map will
choose for every single parameter Pi in
your multinomial it will choose it to be
uh this expression which is the value
which maximizes uh the probability
distribution of the deer
slay okay so I'm going to really quickly
note that most people choose a
particular deay which is that they
Imagine One outcome of every type we'll
talk about this a little bit more on
Friday's class so I'll actually save
this for Friday's
class I do want to take a moment though
and get a little bit deeper into the
math because the plot line so far of map
is this okay we have a new
philosophy and this new philosophy seems
elegant but so far we've seen it work in
different cases but we don't have the
ability to solve it ourselves so if I
gave you a new case Could you actually
come up with an map estimate what if you
you had to come up with what to do for
updating your belief in a
Lambda so are you guys ready for the
slide that puts together all the Cs 109
Concepts you've learned so far not all
of them but a lot of
them
okay I would like to give you a general
way of doing maximum a posterior
yourselves so far we've got some
intuition but now is where we see the
cold hard math at the end of the day the
key Insight is we want to choose the
that are most likely given our data set
that is the opposite condition of
mle B theorem tells us what we can
do we can say if we want to choose the
argmax of our parameters given the
data if we put this into Bas theorem it
gives us that this should be the
likelihood of what's on the right side
of the conditional given what's on the
left side so B theorem flips those two
in the numerator then it has the
probability
of the this term on its own that was
your prior before your posterior and
then you have this term on the bottom
which is just How likely is the data not
conditioned on
parameters remember that in base theorem
we called this term the prior we called
this the likelihood term and we called
this the
posterior now in base term what do we
call this bottom
thing yeah the normalization constant
because as Theta changes values this
doesn't change values like IFA equal 1
this will be the exact same as IFA equal
2 it's a constant and so if you say
which value of theta maximizes this and
that's just a big constant the argmax of
a constant times a function is the same
as the argmax of the function itself
this whole normalization constant goes
away one small thing for notation I am
actually going to flip these two terms
even though we almost always wrote Bas
theorem with likelihood times prior
because prior multiplication is um uh we
can change the order of the
multiplication and it's going to make
things much easier so I'm just going to
put the G over here is that
okay
okay I'm going to drive things step by
step actually I'm going to drive what's
on the board step by step the next step
is because we always assume our data
points are I ID when we talk about the
likely of our data given the parameters
this actually becomes a product of the
likelihood of each data point on its own
given the parameters we did the same
step for mle so this is a pretty
reasonable step to take me from this
line to this
line the next step is um we're going to
use the fact that ARG Max of a constant
times an expression is the same as ARG
Max of an expression itself I can maybe
convince you of
this if you want to find argmax of this
expression
If instead I give you two times this
function whichever argument maximizes
this is going to be the same argument
that maximizes two times that function
so if you multiply any function by a
constant the argmax ignores that
constant so at this point I have a
mathematical expression for saying if
you want to choose an map estimate for
your parameters you should be using this
expression now before when we did mle we
had an expression that looked like this
and we wanted to choose the thetas that
maximized it instead of maximizing it
directly we chose the Theta that
maximize the log of it it was a really
cool trick and we're going to use that
trick one last time if you do the argmax
not of this expression but the log of
this expression what these two terms
will become the log of this term plus
the log of this term the log of this
term we already know what it is it's
just the sum of the logs of each of the
likelihoods and then the log of this
term will just become a log of a
prior this is how people do map if you
want to use this other philosophical way
of choosing parameters you end up with a
pretty similar algorithm and that pretty
similar algorithm is going to say choose
the parameters that maximize this
expression it has a term that just looks
a lot like mle but you also have a term
for your belief that Theta was the
actual parameter before you started any
experimentation so you're going to end
up with an estimated parameter you're
going to do that by using an ARG Max
choose the value of your parameter that
maximizes this thing it has the sum of
log likelihoods but it also has a log
term for a prior belief in your
parameters so just to fill out this
slide from before
mle says if you want to choose a Theta
mle you're going to AR Max over this
nice little
expression Maxim a posterior after we
did all this different philosophical
stuff and we had all this long
conversation look how similar this
equation ended up being we're going to
choose the thetas that maximize this
expression and this expression has a
term that looks exactly like mle it's
just got one extra term all this
complicated Exposition just to say hey
you want to have priors that that's fine
we're just going to have a term in your
log likelihood function for the prior
belief that you had in your parameter
and it all comes from Bas theem we can
derive it step by step but it leads to
this very very nice result two different
philosophies for choosing parameters one
requires you to have a prior and it will
just become a prior
term yes I don't understand what
G's yeah yeah sorry sorry G is just
saying like uh you had a prior belief in
your parameter uh put the probability
density of that prior belief here so if
your prior belief was a uniform this
could be a uniform if your prior belief
was a beta this could be a beta
probability density function let's
actually put that to the test Oh and
before I move on though I do want you
guys to notice that those two terms are
exactly the same and so mle and MP are
actually very very
similar okay uh I want to you can do the
Bruni but I actually feel like this is
going to make a lot more sense
sorry when I do one last Express um I
want to skip to this example okay I want
to do this example and I want to do it a
little bit slowly because I feel like
once you can do this example then
everything else will make a lot of sense
let's go back to this thing we solved
before before I said I give you a whole
bunch of data points I tell you that all
of my data points come from a Paro
distribution that's something you hadn't
seen before but it has a PDF from now
you'll be able to do parameter
estimation whether or not you've seen a
random variable before or whether or not
you've seen a model as long as somebody
gives you a PDF or pmf you should be
able to do parameter estimation the
problem is going to look exactly the
same but I want to use this new
philosophy and this new philosophy is
going to be maximum a posteriority
choose the most likely parameters given
the data so there's your data and I want
you to choose the most likely value of
the parameters the one extra piece of
information I now have to give you is my
belief in the parameters before I see
any
information this time I didn't choose a
really fancy conjugate prior because I
want you to show show you that this
works even if you don't use a fancy
conjugate prior I chose a pretty silly
prior I said before I started any of
this experimentation I have a belief in
my parameter I believe that it's normal
I believe that's normal around 2. oh I
think I did my math using two uh with
variance equal to three but anyways I
express a prior and just like the
envelope sometimes a prior can really
help you come up with a good better
estimate of your parameters if you can
have a good prior you can do better with
less
data now let's see if we can do the math
because if you can do the math for this
that's kind of like the high water mark
for understanding Maxim a
posterior Maxim a posterior says that
there's this thing we don't call it the
log likelihood function instead we're
going to call it the map function but
it's just the same as the log likelihood
function Plus
the log of your prior belief in your
parameter so this we derived earlier I
don't want to lose anybody on this but
this term comes from we had figured out
what was uh the log of the likelihood
function for the PTO and when we did
this earlier in class we got this
expression if you want to do maximum a
posterior we're going to choose an alpha
that maximizes not just this expression
but that expression plus a term for the
prior somebody asked earlier what is g
of alpha
in this problem you should be able to
figure out what is g of
alpha just to be clear I told you that
my prior belief is that Alpha is a
normal so G is supposed to be your prior
belief in a particular setting of
alpha yeah this is normal distribution
yeah but not CDF or pedf um the pedf is
exactly the PDF this will be the PDF
evaluated at Alpha so remember the I
think I solv this using mean equals 2
and variance equals 3 so if you know
mean equals 2 and variance equal 3 you
can say what is the density at Alpha and
the density at Alpha would just look
like putting Alpha into the PDF
expression and as I said I used two for
mean so this is what that expression
looks like I put in the mean I put in
the variance uh and I got this
expression
now the other terms stay the same I do
want to split this up the log of this
expression will be the log of this term
plus the log of that term and we split
it up the log of this term is going to
be like some crazy
constant but when you do the log of that
term check out what happens you'll have
log of something base e those things go
away and you'll just be left with this
expression so this expression saying
instead of just doing log likely I'm
going to do log likelihood press a prior
term when we work it out we end up with
we're going to choose the alpha that
maximizes this
thing before we're choosing the alpha
that maximized just the term on the
right now we're choosing the alpha that
maximizes this whole term which
incorporates a prior
belief I will tell you that well
actually you know if you want to choose
an alpha that maximizes this the first
thing you're going to have to do is
figure out the derivative we're back to
argmax all argmax functions that we know
about required to do a
derivative when we do this derivative we
already did the derivative of the thing
on the right that was n / Alpha minus
the sum over all the logs of your data
points but what's the derivative of K
with respect to
Alpha zero and you know if you expanded
this term you could figure out the
derivative of this term with respect to
um the different values of alpha I
actually believe I'm missing uh this
whole thing I think should be multiplied
by one over six sorry about
that just a really quick
check before we were choosing Alphas
that maximize this term now we have this
prior belief and the prior belief was
that the true parameter value was
gaussian centered around
two notice what happens to the
derivative if you put two in for
Alpha this term will be zero
it says oh my prior belief was it was
two and so I'm not going to be changing
my derivative but if you put a term
that's larger than two here so you put
in like a three that'll be -6 plus 4
it'll be a negative number so if you put
a term that's larger than the mean of
your prior belief this gradient is going
to pull you closer to two and if you put
a term that's smaller than two it's
going to pull you closer to two the
other direction and so it's this little
gravity well around two that's trying to
prevent your parameter from getting too
far away from where you originally
believed it would be so anyways once you
have this derivative then you can do
argmax you could use you know gradient
Ascent all paths lead to gradient Ascent
here if you have a derivative and just
to drive that home you could have
actually just you know done your
derivative calculation with a slightly
different starting point uh for how you
calculate your gradient but you can
still use gradient Ascent or gradient
descent
okay
so to be
clear we are doing all of this because
we would like to build machine learning
algorithms if you come back on Friday
you will learn about our first machine
learning algorithm in CS 109 we'll build
an algorithm that can solve a general
important task all of these algorithms
are going to rely on the mathematics and
the philosophy that you guys have worked
so hard to build a foundation for we
learned about unbias estim they're not
so useful we talked about maximum
likelihood estimation very nice math
very easy to use very general but with a
small problem that it sometimes overfits
data and now we did beijan estimation
called map maximum a posterior which
basically is mle but it has a term for a
prior belief on parameters now that
you've worked so hard to build this
Foundation we can celebrate we can have
a fun time come back on Friday we will
celebrate we will use this to actually
solve naive Bays then we will learn
about logistic aggression then we put it
together into a whole neural network and
it will be a party thank you guys very
much for working so hard today see you
on
Friday